all right john kuhn who played fullback
with the green bay packers and knows
aaron rodgers was on cbs sports radio
last night with zach gelb let's listen
to here or let's listen to here let's
listen to what listen to what listen to
here they know who they know what we
mean some of the things john kuhn had to
say about the aaron rodgers situation
last night cbs sports radio
i have talked with aaron rodgers and i i
won't say exactly what we talked about i
i will say
he's conflicted because this man loves
to play the game of football this man
loves to be a green bay packer and this
man
truly sees
careers he's watched friends leave he
watched brett favre's career um towards
the end he's watched all these things
play out in front of his eyes he's taken
notes throughout his entire career he's
seen
some situations that that didn't feel
were done or or finished the way that
they could or should have and he's just
trying to take his own destiny within
his own hands and to that effect i
actually admire him because
not many players in the nfl have that
opportunity i sure as heck didn't
i i played until everybody told me you
can't play anymore and it's a humbling
feeling and aaron rodgers has an
opportunity to try and you know take a
little bit of that power back so he
hasn't ruled out a return to green bay
is what you're telling me are you saying
that absolutely not absolutely not he is
i i still believe there is an
opportunity that is at a resolution here
and i just think it it's gonna take
uh it's it's gonna take two men that are
dug in right now and trying to meet in
the middle somewhere where they're both
happy
let me say this
if
john kuhn number one speaks to aaron
rodgers and then number two pivots to
do media and talk about it
he's either doing that at the
express or implied direction of rogers
or he is risking
joining the list the list that i've been
on for 10 years that others have been
added to the list that has become a a
full-blown notebook i i don't think that
this was a mistake i don't either i
could fairly call john [ __ ] a surrogate
for aaron rodgers aimed at getting the
message out as to what he wants and [ __ ]
also said he wants more insurance that
he's going to be a long-term starting
quarterback option he doesn't want to do
it on a lame duck contract you mentioned
the lame duck contract earlier chris
we've we rarely nail something
like absolutely positively nail it yeah
we have nailed
the assessment of the fundamental
problem in the relationship right for
months yeah
the packers want
to have him
in that year at a time
will decide based upon how he plays in
any given year whether to continue the
relationship or whether to pivot to
jordan love 2020 okay yeah we're keeping
him he was the mvp 2021 we'll see if
he's good enough he'll be back in 2022.
after that we'll see and to constantly
have that power that sword of damocles
hovering over aaron rodgers as it
relates to the power the packers have to
say at any given year see you later he
doesn't want that no he wants the kind
of contract and bob mcginn reported at
one point that the packers have offered
to make aaron rodgers i saw that right
player in football but that doesn't work
with a contract right that doesn't have
a structure that forces you right
together forces them together for two or
three years
that's what he wants the
the amount is a separate question
the impact of the contract with the
guarantees and more importantly the cap
hit yes it's the cap hit if it's a
crippling cap it that comes from trading
him that's when
you truly have a relationship that is
not one year at a time and i think they
had a chance to do that they blew their
opportunity and now it's going to take
something along those lines and you know
kuhn stop short of saying they've got to
trade jordan love or they've got to fire
brian gudykoon but at the same time the
end result has got to amount to an
apology
basically a public apology to aaron
rodgers without coming out and buying
billboards that say we're sorry right
but it creates a scenario where jordan
loves never going to be the quarterback
so you may as well trade him
and that it's clear to anyone who's been
paying attention that aaron rodgers has
won the tug of war with brian gudykunst
and the move that was made last year to
get jordan love ends up being a nullity
useless gone over kaput do you think
green bay would do that though do you
like you know that that's where i i i
don't know that's where i'm i'm
conflicted in this situation of course
i've done it by now i may have done it
right that's right that's yeah i would
think so now i mean does all this public
pressure and everything that's going on
you know force their hand make them
think differently maybe change but yeah
i'm with you you're right they would
have done it by now they had to know
this storm was brewing i mean like we've
talked about a lot you don't fly out to
california and do all that and think
what that it was just gonna totally stay
under the radar all off season i mean
you couldn't have thought that aaron
rodgers and being who he is and the
stubborn man he seems to be and
everything like that and calculating
this was gonna be
like a quiet you know open
shut door type of situation where we
weren't going to hear about it again
so that's where you know i again i i
don't know who's going to bend here i
think rogers will bend a little bit
if they just come to his side a little
because i have a hard time going back to
two things we've talked about
rogers like you have always said
i don't think wants to get his hands
dirty in this type of thing this is not
this is not what he likes he doesn't
like this i think the history shows that
he doesn't like being the bad guy you've
always said that the other thing is too
that i come back to but just with what
kuhn said
it's a guy that's
37
and 37 is like it's is like early 30s
back 20 years ago now he's got
big time football left in front of him i
mean i can't imagine him i know the
threat of walking away from the game but
what i mean
we're talking about a guy you know two
years from now it's another it's another
100 touchdowns it's it's 500 and it's
another stratosphere of you know
legendary quarterback list or whatever
else so that's where i just i can't
imagine him wanting to give his high
level of play away right now but i it
just doesn't sound like green bay is
going to make any concessions here to
give power uh give some power back to
rogers
and the point that we made yesterday and
the more that i've thought about it
talked about it
considered it
if i'm mark murphy the ceo of the
packers
i would rather he retire get back 30
million that i've already paid him avoid
14.7 million in salary this year and not
have to worry
about
what happens if he ends up with the
broncos or some other team yeah how many
super bowls he may win somewhere else
how many super bowls he possibly will
win against the packers what kind of a
thorn he'll be in my side over the
balance of his career and if after a few
years and a super bowl or two with
another team he
mutually agrees to depart that team and
signs with the vikings or the lions or
the bears we don't know what's going to
happen in three or four years you don't
want that
just give us our money back
retire play for us or play for no one i
really do think the packers are in that
mindset play for us or play for no one
and
chris any opportunities they've had to
bridge that chasm yeah as mike tarico
characterized it after talking to aaron
rodgers on saturday any opportunities
they've come and gone they had three
months so i don't know
now that it's at defcon 1 i don't know
what other options there are
that they haven't already explored
unless somebody finally said well i
guess they were serious
and capitulates but i feel like people
are too dug in
to give in you know there's the stuff we
know publicly there's the fight that we
don't know about
yet
but if someone
basically
gives up
surrenders taps out
submits
i have a feeling we're going to find out
and i think that's part of this too i
know wants to be the one who gives up
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports